[Music]
this landmark speech in march 1971 by
sheikh mujibur rahman popularly known as
bangabundu inspired the bengali people
in what was then is pakistan to rise up
and prepare for a war of independence
since we have given blood we'll give
more of it but inshallah will free the
people of this land the struggle this
time is for emancipation the struggle
this time is for independence
when bangladesh became an independent
country nine months later bongo bondu
became its first president and later
prime minister
ayubali now in his late 70s and a former
freedom fighter visits the bangladesh
liberation war museum with his family he
does not want the next generation to
forget the sacrifices that were made
we loved bangabandhu and he is the one
who inspired us to go to war and fight
for our independence with our life so
that we can live in a free country we
have achieved many things and are happy
about it
another former fighter survived several
bullet wounds 50 years ago but says he's
disappointed bangladesh is still not
fully self-reliant
we went to war to liberate ourselves
from domination and become independent
since then the nation has developed a
lot and has changed a great deal but so
much more needs to be done so that we
are truly a self-reliant country
during the nine-month conflict in 1971
nearly 10 million bengalis took refuge
in india zafarulla a young physician
left the uk to join the liberation war
and set up a field hospital in india we
fought for
for democracy
for equality
and
we have achieved certain things
we live we live longer
we don't
[Music]
suffer from hunger
but we have no democracy
we have no world
we are so
so
and this is autocracy without a
democracy
without a freedom of his speech
without the equality
a country is meaningless
once timed a bottomless basket case by
former u.s secretary of state henry
kissinger bangladesh now has one of the
fastest growing economies in the world
and is scheduled to officially become a
developing country in 2026.
bangladesh has achieved matched over the
past 50 years but the nation is still
very polarized between two main rival
political parties for many the
aspiration for democracy free and fair
election still remains a major challenge
bangladesh has defied many expectations
since it's about 50 years ago but is
facing more obstacles on the political
front its over population and the
effects of climate change tanvi
choudhary al jazeera dhaka